no hay anuncios sobre aviones pero los
aliados de Ucrania se comprometieron a
dar toda la munición posible en la
reunión de los ministros de defensa de
la otan en Bruselas de este martes el
Secretario de Defensa de Estados Unidos
dijo que Ucrania Estaba preparando una
contraofensiva a partir de mediados de
marzo y que la alianza se centraba en
asegurarse de que kiev dispusiera de La
potencia de fuego el blindaje y la
logística necesaria para hacerla
efectiva
es una tarea Monumental reunir todos
esos sistemas y entrenar a las tropas en
esas plataformas así como asegurarnos de
que contamos con el mantenimiento de
todos esos sistemas y de que entran en
combate Así que ese es realmente el tema
central de nuestra conversación de hoy
en el campo de batalla en bakmuth
Moscú se atrinchera con la mayor parte
de los recursos de Rusia dirigidos a la
ciudad clave del este el gobernador
regional declaró a los medios locales
que ni un metro cuadrado de la ciudad
estaba a salvo del fuego Ruso y de los
drones según Washington los progresos de
Rusia han sido lentos y con los soldados
recién reclutados mal entrenados y mal
equipados el índice de bajas es alto
su liderazgo y su moral no son buenos y
están luchando mucho sin embargo tienen
números y como saben el presidente Putin
hizo un llamado a varios cientos de
miles y esa gente ha estado llegando al
campo de batalla
el martes la otan Se comprometió a
mantener el flujo de municiones a kiev
después de que el jefe de la alianza
James dijera que los ucranianos estaban
agotando los proyectiles mucho más
rápido de lo que los aliados podrían
producirlos además Ucrania podría
necesitar pronto más municiones que
nunca ante la preocupación de que Rusia
pueda intensificar su ofensiva